hey guys welcome to a session on
selenium interview questions by simply
lung in this video we will look at most
commonly asked questions in the
interview and some guidelines on how to
answer them nowadays automation tool and
especially the selenium skills is a very
key requirement for an engineer or even
an automation engineer jobs so if you're
on an Outlook of automation engineer or
a QA engineer positions I'm sure this
question Bank will definitely help you
prepare for your interview so this video
consists of three parts basically three
different levels of set of questions one
is the beginner level second is the
intermediate level and then the advanced
level questions and each level has a set
of ten most probable questions which you
might be asked in the interview so let's
begin with the beginner level questions
question 1 what are selenium suite
components so selenium is a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
on web applications you already know
this it does not a single tool so what
are those components which are comprised
in the selenium so selenium counts with
four major components the first one is
the ID ID happens to be the most
simplest tool in the whole suite of
selenium it is nothing but an integrated
development environment which has a
record and playback functionality this
was earlier available as only Firefox
plugin however you need to know that the
new version of selenium IDE is available
as a Chrome extension as well as a
Firefox plugin so that means you can
either use any of the browsers that is
Firefox or the Chrome for recording your
desk reps also you should also know that
the new ID comes with many new features
and now this new ID has become more
powerful than what was available earlier
so some of these new features are like
reusability of your test cases it comes
with a better debugger now and most
importantly it supports parallel test
execution and how does it do that
it has a utility called selenium side
Runa that's about selenium ID the next
component is the selenium remote control
so selenium remote control or popularly
called a selenium
RC is used to write web application test
in different programming languages it
supports multiple programming languages
like Java C sharp pull Python Ruby and
PHP it does nothing but it's a server
which interacts with your browser using
a simple HTTP GET and post requests for
communication selenium RC is also called
as selenium one daughter version or
selenium core third component selenium
webdriver it is a programming interface
to run your test cases and webdriver was
introduced by Simon Stewart in 2006 and
this was introduced to overcome some of
the limitations of selenium RC so our
SACEUR architecture was very complex
because it required an additional server
in its setup and why was that additional
server for communicating with the
browser and what webdriver did was it
removed this dependency completely
webdriver interacts directly with the
browser and also makes your test cases
run much faster than your RC the last
component the selenium grid a very
important tool this is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time now with the
selling of webdriver you can only do
sequential execution but in real-time
environment you always have the need to
run test cases in a distributed
environment so this grid allows parallel
execution of tests on different browsers
as well as different operating system so
the design is in such a way that
commands are distributed on multiple
machines where you want to run the tests
and they're executed simultaneously this
uses a simple hub and node concept where
hub controls the whole execution of your
test cases on the nodes and this is how
we achieve parallel execution and what
is a major advantage of having this grid
it is to reduce your overall test
execution time question - what are the
limitations of selenium now like any
other tool selenium also has certain
limitations so when you are answering
this question you will also be expected
to talk about what is the workaround
available for all these limitations so
let's look at them one by one no
reliable tech support of course selenium
is an open source so if you look at it
you
do not have much technical support
available however there are loads of
documentation available there are forums
available which you can refer to
selenium HQ dot orgy is the website is
your Bible if you're working with the
selenium and then there are there are a
lot of selenium Google Groups and the
forums which are available for any kind
of support so selenium has been there
for quite some time so it's it's one of
the most mature tool available today so
even though we do not have a technical
support available there is enough
documentation available on the Internet
the second limitation selenium can test
only web application
selenium is a open source tool that is
designed to automate web-based
applications on different browsers but
it cannot handle Windows GUI or non HTML
pop-ups in the application now what is a
workaround available for that selenium
provides a support for integrating other
tools like auto it so auto editor the
tool for handling your windows-based
activity selenium also cannot automate
mobile applications but then what is
available with that it can integrate a
tool called a PM tool which is a mobile
automation tool the third limitation
limited support for image testing
selenium is a de-facto tool for
functional web app web application tests
so standard API allows interacting only
with the browser and it's hard to test
the images based applications using
selenium what is the other tool
available securely is a very good tool
to use for image testing and this again
you can integrate securely with selenium
that's how you can achieve your image
testing through selenium but using the
securely tool no built-in reporting
facility so selenium does not have any
reporting capability as such of course
it does provide a very limited reporting
capability where some basic reports are
created but definitely when you are
working in a framework you need a better
support for good reporting tools so that
way selenium supports some of the tools
like test ng report ng and extended
force using which you can integrate
these tools with selenium and generate
beautiful reports limited test
management selenium does not provide any
tests or integration with test
management tools may require knowledge
of programming
languages so since selenium supports
multiple programming languages the
developer of the test automation will
require to have some basic knowledge of
any of the supported programming
language y1 in order to write your
effective automation scripts and of
course because selenium tool you want to
use it at its full potential question 3
what are the testing types supported by
selenium so selenium supports regression
testing and functional testing these can
be called as a very high-level
categories so what is regression testing
regression testing is a full or partial
selection of already executed test cases
which are really to ensure your existing
functionality does not break so let's
look at what are these attributes of
regression testing and why we say that
selenium helps us in doing regression
testing so regression tests are run
every time or new fix has been received
or a new feature has been deployed so
that is called as retesting you can
always select a full suite or selected
test to test a fix or a complete product
so your selection can be based on
recently added features a test area
where most effects are there or
integration areas or even end-to-end
kind of yes you can also prioritize your
test cases based on critical
functionalities and business impact of
these test cases according to the
priority set so all this can be done
using selenium now what is the second
category of the testing which it
supports functional testing so
functional testing includes what your
smoke test sanity tests say installed as
data base tests basically any kind of
functionality which you are going to
test and if you look at the kind of
steps which are involved in that it
involves identification of your test
inputs expected outputs or the results
the test case logic itself and the
assertions so a typical flow will be you
identify your test inputs first then you
derive your test outcomes or the
expected outputs you design and execute
your test cases and then assert on the
expected vs. actual outcomes question 4
what are selenium 2 dot o and 3 daughter
versions so selenium was introduced by
gentlemen Khan Jason Huggins way back
into
2004 and that was selenium version since
then this tool has gone through multiple
changes to make it better and better
so if selenium turret version had a
major change it took a leap forward in
terms of browser automation the selenium
RC the remote control had a disadvantage
of having the need of an additional
server to talk to the web browsers and
because of this the text execution was
much slower and the copper architecture
itself became very complex so if you
look at the selenium 2 it had two
components a successor to RC and RC
itself which is called as your core so
this successor was nothing but your
webdriver 88 so webdriver API is made it
easier to write your automation scripts
for any browser by simply using a
suitable driver for any browser which
you want to run the tester apart from
these two component the selenium 2 dot o
version also had the ID and the grid
components so in summary if you look at
it selenium 2 dot for worship has an ID
it has selenium RC which was on its way
of deprecation webdriver API which was
just introduced in this a very very
earlier version of webdriver API and the
grid
so what did selenium 3 dot o consists so
selenium 3 dot o R she was completely
eliminated now because into rato it was
already on its path of deprecation and
webdriver replaced RC completely so you
if you look at the components of three
dot o we have ID we have a webdriver and
grid as the major components so now with
this introduction of webdriver a
full-fledged webdriver selenium became
the most powerful tool for web
application automation question 5 a very
important question what the same origin
policy and how was the tangle now same
origin policy is a security IT feature
so it is a very important concept in web
application security model and what is
this according to this policy a web
browser allows scripts from one web page
to access the contents of another web
page provided both these pages are on
the same origin now what does origin
mean origin is nothing but a combination
of your URL schema
host number and a port number it's
basically your domain now if a course
such question is asked how are you going
to explain it so let's say you have a
JavaScript program which runs in a
certain domain say google.com okay so
this program can access all the programs
which are from the same origin now
origin here is what google.com so for
example you can access other pages like
your Google Drive your Google email or
your Google Calendar however now if you
use the same JavaScript right so if you
use the same script from the google.com
to access another page or an element in
a different domain say yahoo.com then
the security model of the web
application itself prohibits you to do
so
so what happens because of that is you
are limited with access only to those
elements and pages which are in the same
domain but now look at the case that you
want to run your test on multiple
servers and you might also want to
access multiple domains so due to the
same origin policy you will not be able
to do so and this became a major
limitation with a very early selenium to
it so how was this handled so this got
handled by Paul Hammond who created the
selenium remote control so he created
the selenium remote control server to
trick the browser in believing that the
selenium core and the web application
under test actually came from the same
to me and this is how the same origin
policy was handled and this a selenium
RC which is selenium remote control
became the version 1 of selenium
question 6 what is Cellini's and how was
it classified selenium commands for
selenium ID are often called as
Cellini's they are a set of commands
that run your tests and sequence of this
command is called as a test script now
these commands are categorized into
three major categories one is the action
command now action commands are the
commands that generally manipulate the
state of your application for example
they can do things like click on this
link or select a particular option open
a URL type certain text into an input
box click or double-click on any web
element and so on so these are called as
action commands the second set of
commands is the axises now
Scissors examine the state of the
application and store the results in a
variable so it basically allows the user
to store certain values to a
user-defined variable for example if I
want to store the page title of a
webpage I can do that by defining a
user-defined variable and then these
store values can be later used to create
your assertions or verifications in your
tests now a few examples of such
commands are you can just use a store
sto re or a store text store title or a
store value so these are some of the
accessor commands the third category is
the assertions assertions are like your
accessors but they verify the state of
your application and conforms to what is
expected so basically it is a comparison
of your actual versus expected results
there are two types of assertions
available one is the soft positions and
the hard decisions an example of our
soft assertion can be verified title
wherein you verify the title check
whether the expected and the actual
outcomes are the same and continue with
your test case now whereas an hard
assertion is you do an assert title
using the command assert title and if at
all the assertion fails the test case
stops from executing question 7 mention
the types of web locator what is web
locator a locator is a command that
tells the selenium which UI element you
want to operate on selenium uses
locators to find and match the elements
of your webpage which it needs to
interact with and there are around 8
locating techniques in selenium the
first one is by ID now this is the most
common way of locating elements why
since the IDS are supposed to be unique
for each element the IDS can also be
dynamic in nature so you can identify
them by inspecting the attributes of the
web element so let's look at an example
so if we go to a Facebook right so if
you go to the Facebook and say if I want
to identify this element email so if you
look at this highlighted text here it
has a unique ID which is email so if I'm
going to operate on this particular
element email I can directly use the ID
locating Technic link text and the
partial link text so this type of
locator applies only to the hyperlink
text
we access the link by using this locator
which needs the hyperlinked text to be
provided so for link text you can give a
complete text in the link text or let's
let's look at an example of that
so let's if you go to say one of the
e-commerce site which is say Amazon dot
in and say you want to click on this
today's T link so if you look here in
Amazon dot in there are lot of
hyperlinks available here and if an
example if you have to take an example
say we want to click on the today's T
now if you inspect this element you will
see that it has an anchor tag a it has
an Associated H ref link here and also
it has a text which says today's T right
which is what is displayed on your web
page now similarly there is also a link
available here called customer service
so if you inspect that customer service
it also has something similar what the
today is still had it has an anchor tab
it has an H ref link and it has a long
text which says customer service which
is what is displayed now if you have to
use your web locator which is a link
text you need to provide the complete
text which is displayed on your webpage
and there is another way of using the
link text by saying partial link text
where you can just give a partial text
which can be matched against the
complete text of your link and this is
how you can use your partial link text
or the link text the next ID is by name
so locating elements by name is very
similar to locating by ID just that your
attribute instead of using an ID you're
going to use name in this case now if
you look at the same example of say
Facebook we identified this email
element using its ID you can also locate
the same element by using the name
attribute which is also unique in this
case which has a value called email tag
name that's the next identifier so
locate element using tag name of the
element now say if you want to identify
all the elements on your webpage which
are of type 'button so that you can do
by using the tag name s button there for
example again on your Facebook page I
know that there is a single button here
which is of type button and which has a
tag as button and this is the only
button which is available on this page
so if I want to access this particular
element
I can simply use a locator technique
called tack which is button in this case
next locator class name so locate an
element using its class name attribute
so you can use this identifier only if
you find that a class name is unique for
a web element which you want to work
with class names are sometimes unique a
web element can also have multiple class
name or even you will find some elements
which has no class name so depending on
what is available in the attributes you
can use this class name for
identification so example the Shonan on
your screen here where it says find
element by class name input text
basically this is going to list out all
elements on your webpage which has a
class name called input text the next
identifier is by XPath now expert is a
language used when locating XML notes
what is XML extendable markup language
it can access almost any element even
those without any class names or names
or even ID attributes so whenever you do
not find a unique attribute for ID name
or class name you can construct an XPath
to create an unique identifier for that
particular element now for example on
this Facebook page if you observe here
there is a label here called create an
account so if you inspect this
particular label it has no attributes
other than a tag called SPAC so if you
want to identify this particular element
and say displayed this is one of the
ways to do it is through XPath CSS
selector so C is the selector our string
patterns used to identify an element
based on the combination of either the
HTML tag ID class or any other
attributes locating by CSS selector is
little more complicated than any of the
previous method however the advantages
see if the selectors work much faster
than the experts the performance of your
test scripts is much better when you use
CSS selector than any other locating
technique now again as an example if you
see the Facebook again you can identify
the same email here right I used an ID
here or a name attribute here to
identified so assume that if you did not
have any of those things or if you want
to use a CSS selector here you can still
do that
by using this syntax this is how you use
this
selector to identify an element question
eight what are the types of weights
supported by web tribal now before even
you answer this question you should know
why do we need weights in selenium
weights play a very important role in
executing test cases most of the web
applications are developed using using
Ajax and JavaScript so when a page is
loaded by the browser the elements which
you want to interact may load at a
different time intervals not only this
makes it difficult to identify the
elements but also if the element is not
located it will start throwing element
not visible exception and how do we
resolve this by using the weights so
there are three different kind of
weights available in selenium first one
is the implicit weight the implicit
weight tells the browser or your web
driver to wait for a certain amount of
time before it can throw no such element
exception now the default setting is
zero for this once we set a time what
web read web driver does it it will wait
for that time say if you mentioned ten
seconds it will wait for ten seconds
until it finds the element and even in
the ten seconds it is unable to find
that element only after that it throws
an exception now what is the syntax of
this implicit wait is this is the syntax
of this where you use driver dot manage
time odds implicit wait and there is a
timeout value say ten seconds and the
unit whether it's in minutes seconds or
milliseconds is what you can mention
implicit weight is applied globally to
all the elements which means it is
available for all the web elements
throughout the driver instance implicit
weight is defined only once and it will
remain same throughout the driver object
instance now let's see what explicit
weight is so explicit weight is used to
tell the web driver to wait for certain
conditions before throwing an element
not visible exception it is defined to
wait for certain expected conditions
only now these expected conditions can
check whether the element is displayed
on the web page or not or can be clicked
or not so any kind of conditions you can
mention there so these are called as
conditional weights and they are applied
on a web element on a single web element
unlike the implicit weight which was
kind of applied
globally to all ailments it is
definitely recommended to use this
explicit weights when your elements are
taking longer time to load and also for
verifying the property of the elements
likes a visibility of the element
located element to be clickable
clickable or element to be selected then
we have fluent wit now fluent weight is
used to tell the web driver to wait for
a condition that is very similar to the
explicit weight as well as a frequency
with which we want to keep checking the
condition before throwing the not
visible exception so fluent weight is
used to define the maximum amount of
time you want the web driver to wait for
a condition then if you look in the
syntax then there is polling every
second so polling every and you give a
timeout this could be like five seconds
so start polling to see whether the web
element is available or not say once in
three seconds once in four seconds
depending on your use kiss and then dot
ignoring so you can also try to ignore
specific type of exceptions while
waiting now for example such as no such
element exception which is sometimes
thrown when searching for an element on
the page so you can mention even that
here so fluent Wright takes two
parameters one is the timeout value and
the polling frequency so when we have
web elements which sometimes are visible
after a few seconds or sometimes it
takes more time than usual like we have
a Jax applications as an example we can
set a default polling period based on
our requirement and then as I said you
can also ignore some of the exceptions
by pulling this element question nine
mention the types of navigation commands
available in selenium so webdriver
provides a basic browser navigation
commands that allows the browser to move
forward backward refresh and using the
browser history and this is done using
some of the driver dot navigate methods
right so these are some of the commonly
used navigation methods first one is
navigate to so this method loads a new
web page in the existing browser window
and it accepts string as a parameter and
returns nothing so it's a void so the
URL you mentioned here needs to be a
fully-formed
you are driver dot navigate dot refresh
so this method refreshes or reloads the
current webpage in the existing browser
window it neither accepts anything so
there is no value path or it returns
thing forward so this method enables the
web browser to click on the forward
button in the existing browser window
again this has this has no arguments to
be passed or it returns nothing driver
dot navigate dot back so this method
enables the web browser to click on the
back button in the existing browser
window again this returns nothing nor it
meets any argument question ten what is
the major difference between driver dot
closed and driver dot quitter so this is
again a very important question and
pretty confusing also sometimes so
selenium webdriver provides two methods
for closing the browser window one is
browser dot closed and the other one is
the browser dot quit so you might think
to use them interchangeably and that's
that's what everybody thinks that both
anyway does the same function so it can
be used however it is not so both are
two different methods
now driver door close command is used to
close the current browser window which
is having the focus and in case if there
is a only single browser window open
then calling this driver dot close
actually quits the complete browser
session now it is used when you are
working with say multiple browser tabs
or windows and you want to just close
one of them which is in focus in the
test whereas the driver dot quit is used
to quit the complete browser session
along with all its associated windows
tabs pop-ups and everything so when do
you use browser dot quit it is best to
use use browser quit or sorry driver
door quit when you no longer want to
interact with the driver object along
with all its associated windows tabs and
pop-ups generally it is one of the last
statements of your automation scripts so
in case you are like working with
selenium of a test and G or goj unit we
usually call this driver dot quit in the
after suite that is at after suite
method of our test fit the spice by
doing that we close the complete browser
session at the end of the test with
execution now let's look at some
intermediate level questions question 11
how to type in an input box using
selenium so selenium provides a method
or a command you can say to insert value
into any of the input box and this
command is called as a send keys come on
so send keys is a method available in a
web element now this is how you use the
send key so here is an
sample so first you need to find the
element using any of the eight locating
techniques and once you find the element
in this case which is an email field you
need to call a method called send keys
send keys takes an argument which is of
type string so you can pass the value
which you want to pass to the web
element so in this case we'll be passing
a gmail ID or any ID which will be your
email ID here and then similarly you do
it for your password field
so we first you find the element
password and then you send the password
using send keys there's a very simple
method to use question twelve how to
click on a hyperlink in selenium so
wherever you are testing the e-commerce
application you are going to find lot of
hyperlinks on your web pages which you
will obviously need to test now selenium
provides two locating techniques using
which you can identify this hyperlinks
and using these is what you need to
operate on the hyperlinks on your
webpages so one is using link text and
other one is using partial in text so
using link text you give a complete text
in the link text that is if you look at
in your e-commerce a let us say Amazon
dot in let's let's go to that website
and see what it means so in the Amazon
dot in if you look at some of these
hyperlink text called today steel or
Amazon pay or sale or customer service
if you inspect this element you will see
that this is associated with our link
text which is called as today's tea
along with this edge ref and of course
an anchor tag so one way of identifying
this link is to use this complete text
which is today's tea also there is
another way by using partial link text
for say example you have a link text
which is pretty long and you do not want
to use this complete text instead you
can use the locating technique called
partial link text and give a partial
text from that in this example instead
of giving the complete customer service
here you can just say use a customer or
you can just use service as your text
only thing water will be required here
is this has to be unique on this page
there shouldn't be two elements which
would have this text which you are going
to use so let's quickly see this in
action how do we use this link text and
partial index now we will be using the
same example of Amazon
so my use-cases first I will click on
this today's deal and after a sleep of 2
or 3 seconds I will also click on
customer service and I'm going to
achieve this one by using link text so
if you see in this program so I have
this method written which is going to
click on today's deal and this is using
a locating Technic link text and then I
also have another method here by using
partial link text I am going to be
clicking on the customer service link
right so let's see how this works so I
just go ahead and execute this so this
launches the Amazon dot in and the first
thing what we are doing is it is going
to click on today steel alright that is
done and then it will click on the
customer service link right so this is
how you can achieve clicking on the
hyperlinks in your web applications
question 13 how to scroll down a page
using javascript this is a very
important question and usually this gets
asked quite often in the interview you
should know that you can run Java
scripts through selenium and selenium
provides a way to do this selenium
provides an interface called JavaScript
executor javascript executor and this
helps in executing any kind of Java
scripts through the selenium webdriver
so this JavaScript executor it has
basically two methods one is execute
script and the other one is execute its
async script to run the JavaScript on
the selected window or on your current
rich but why do you need this right so
if you're answering this question you
should also have a background that why
at all this is required because
sometimes you need to perform certain
functions which cannot be done using the
locators what has been provided like say
scrolling down the web page itself also
sometimes you will see that you are
unable to even identify some of the
elements using all the top locating
techniques which is made available by
selenium so in such situations what you
can do is you can directly write a
JavaScript and execute it using this
JavaScript executor and if you look at
it the syntax is something like this so
it says JavaScript executor J s is equal
to JavaScript executor and tribal now if
you look at this JavaScript executor is
an interface that means you cannot
create an object of it and hence
you typecasted to your driver object now
how do you do this now first thing what
you do is you launch your web
application on whatever web application
is under test and then on that current
window you call this particular execute
script method using the JavaScript
executor and then you can perform any
functions here in this example we are
seeing a function which is crawling down
vertically so this function takes an
attributes or arguments like
x-coordinate and the y-coordinate now in
this example our x-coordinate is 0 and
y-coordinate is 1000 that means when
this command gets executed the page is
going to create scroll down vertically
by thousand pixels so why don't we just
see this in action so let's go to
another program here called the
scrolling tester Java so basically what
I am doing here is I am going to be
logging in to Amazon Rotten and then I
will show you how to scroll down by 600
pixels so it's a very very simple code
to write you launch your application
then you create your object of
JavaScript executors right actually you
typecast it to the driver and then you
just use an execute script command or a
method this you see is your actual
script which gets executed which is
Windows dot scroll by 0 comma 600 which
is x coordinate and y coordinate let's
go ahead and execute this so in Amazon
dot in is launched and you should see
the screen scrolling down yes there we
go so it just crawled on by few pixels
and that's 600 pixels what we mentioned
see I could scroll back again and that
is how you can achieve scrolling
functions and when do you usually use
this say if you have a very long web
page and you want to go and identify or
do some operations on the web element
which is probably available to you
towards the end of the pitch and that is
when you can use some of the scrolling
functions question 14 how to assert the
title of a pitch selenium webdriver
provides webdriver methods and one such
method is called dead title so what gate
title does is it fetches the title of
the current page how to use this command
get titles returns a string which is
nothing but your title of your page that
means you need a string variable in
which you can store this value so what
you do is you define a string variable
like it is defined in this example to
store your title
and then you execute this command driver
dot Kotecha which is going to fetch the
title and that value gets stored in your
actual title once you get the title you
can do any operations with that in this
case what we are doing is we are trying
to verify the title there are two ways
you can verify that one is using an
if-else statement where you compare your
actual title with the expected title or
alternately you can also use assert
statements here let's--oh selenium
provides us assert statements so using a
sir
you can validate whether your title of
the web pages as expected question 15
how to mouse over over an element in
automation many times it is required to
perform some action on the element which
gets visible only on the mouse overing
on those elements now in selenium action
is a class which we can use to achieve
this functionality so action class is
defined in a package called as selenium
interactions this has a set of api's to
emulate complex user gestures it helps
in building the patterns of action and
then perform that action on a web
element now this action class provides a
rich set of aps like so for mouse events
and even the keyboard events so say for
to perform any kind of mouse event it
provides a method called moves to
element now in this example what you do
is you initiate an object of mouse class
and then use this move to element method
and what it does is the element is
crawled into the view first even before
the move operations happen so you could
have multiple actions like here in this
example we are just using move to
element but also UK if you want to do a
drag and drop operation you can still
have that so in such case where you have
multiple actions like a drag and drop
then you use a method called build along
with this so you say actions don't move
two element dot build and then dot
perform so dot build method is called
before the perform method and what it
does is it generates the composite
actions which has all those multiple
actions which you want to perform on a
web element then after the building
action is done you call a perform method
which actually performs that action on
your web element and this is how the
move to element method
of the action class is used why don't we
just see that in action let's say let's
go to our Eclipse here and I have a
mouse over test written here so let's
say we go to amazon.com is on if you go
to the shop by category you see that so
the moment I mouse over it it is going
to give me this drop-down list so for me
to select any element from this my first
action on this webpage should be to go
and just hover my mouse over this web
element called shop by category and
that's exactly I'm going to achieve
through my automation now here in my
methods here what I have written I have
said ok first launch your website which
is Amazon dot in and then I'm finding
that element which is shop by category
using an XPath so you could use any
available locating technique to find the
element first and then I instantiate an
object of actions and then simply I'm
doing is I'm using the method move to
element and then I'm just going to say
perform that means my mouse will
actually get moved or over onto that
particular element okay so let's see
this in action so I just execute this
test case okay so I'm in zone dot and
it's launched and now we should see yeah
the mouse actually moved to shop by
category and because of that we got this
drop-down list so and this is how you
can achieve your mouse over
functionality question 16 how to
retrieve the CSS properties of an
element now see this is nothing but
cascading style sheets it's a style
sheet language used for describing the
presentation of a document written in
your markup language it basically
describes your HTML elements as how they
need to be displayed on the screen it's
basically the look and feel like your
font size the width height color and so
on so it provides a special and easy way
to specify various properties of the
element now why do we need this we need
to use a special method called get CSS
value to retrieve such c-h-s properties
of web intent
why because we already have a method
called get attribute which can retrieve
the value of the attributes right
however the get attribute method can
only retrieve those properties where the
attribute and its value are mentioned in
your dog and
hence all this font size color cannot be
retrieved through the gate attribute
method and that is why we used the get
CSS value so basically it works like
your get method and you need to provide
the attribute which you want to fetch
using the get CSS file so in this
example what we are trying to do is we
have a a web element called the email ID
and of that we are trying to fetch the
font size so let's again check this in
action so if I go to my web page here
let's close this so if I go to my
Facebook and if I inspect this
particular element which is the email id
and on the right if you see there are
multiple other attributes of that
element you see right so you see the
background color you see the color here
then you see something called responses
and say for example we want to retrieve
the font size of this particular weapon
and you will also see on the left where
you are seeing the Dom here you do not
see that font size anywhere as an
attribute and its value here and that is
why I cannot use the gate attribute
method to retrieve it now instead of
that what I am going to do is I'm going
to use the get CSS value and use this
font size for that so let's go to my
Eclipse I have a method return here
where I login into the Facebook and then
I'm going to first find that element
which is by ID and I'm going to retrieve
the CSS value and I'm just simply
printing it on the console so if I
execute this so it's going to launch the
Facebook and since I'm not going to do
anything on the Facebook web page as
such let's go to my console here because
this is where I'm expecting the output
so here it is given with an output in
the console same 12px which is nothing
but your actual font size what you see
here in your HTML page and this is how
you can extract your CSS properties of
any web element on your web page
question 17 what is page object model
popularly known as Bham BHO object model
is a design pattern that helps create
object repositories for web elements so
writing selenium test cases without say
using any patterns may lead to code
duplication and also the code becomes
unmaintainable
after some time and say if you have web
element locators which changes over time
then you will have to go through the
entire code base to make
the required changes so under this model
for each webpage in the application
there should be a corresponding page
class and this page class will have all
the web elements of the web page and
also it contains the page methods which
perform operations on the web elements
and the verification steps required in
your test cases are the separate test
cases it's they are not combined in the
same class now the tests that use the
methods of this page object class
whenever they need to interact with the
UI of that page the benefit here is if
the page UI changes then the tests need
not be changed only the code within this
page object class needs to be changed
that is you go and just change the web
elements or the locators of the web
elements only in one place which is your
page class and not in any of your test
case or not test classes so how does
this form help so it makes the code more
readable maintainable and reusable so
there are two ways you can implement a
poem or a page object model one is done
using the page Factory which is offered
by selenium and then you can also
achieve a page object model without
using the page factor and using directly
the objects and the classes question 18
can capture
be automated this is again a very
favorite question of the interview
capture in the security feature that
prevents bots and automated programs
from accessing sensitive information yes
and CAPTCHA cannot be automated you will
see that there are many applications
today who have captured why because it's
a security feature it is a concept to
differentiate between human and
computers the idea of capture itself is
to prevent any automated process or a
robotic process to do any kind of
actions and say if you are going to
automate it then the entire idea of
having the capture is lost so you should
never attempt to automate it but then
what do you how can you handle this then
one either you can ask your developers
to disable it in the test environment so
that you can test the whole application
without having to hit on this capture
other way of doing this you can use
static data for your capture so that you
get hard code that value in your test
for the time being and then since your
application has capture as one of its
functionality if you really need to test
you can just test that separately as a
manual testing itself but not automate
it question 19 how the selenium handle
windows-based proper selenium is an
automation tool for automating web
applications it cannot handle
windows-based application however we can
use tools like auto 8 and robot class
along with selenium to handle such
proper so what are these tools robot
class is a Java class which along with
selenium can simulate your keyboard and
mouse events it also helps an upload and
download of files and also to manage the
pop-ups so wherever you have a
requirement of doing a file upload
operation in which if your native dialog
box opens up then one of the way to
handle it is using robot class other
tool which is available for us is the
auto it - it is a freeware and what it
does is it uses a combination of your
mouse movement keystrokes and window
control manipulation to automate any
such task which is not possible by
selenium web tiles and again this auto
it tool can be integrated with Cellini
and thus you can achieve the automation
of native window based problems question
20 how to take screenshots in webdriver
take screenshot interface can be used to
take screenshots of webdriver so
selenium provides us this interface for
managing our screenshot operations now
screenshots are desirable for bug
analysis so selenium can automatically
take this screenshots during your
execution you know that it is very
important to take screenshots when we
execute the test scripts say if we have
a huge number of test scripts running
and if some of the test case fail we
need to check why this test case failed
so using the screenshot functionality
it helps us debug and identify the
problem by looking at the screen shots
so webdriver has this built-in
functionality to take the screenshot
across the page and it's pretty easy to
use take screenshot interface is used to
capture the screenshot during the
execution now this interface has a
method called great get screenshot as
which captures a screenshot and it also
stores in a location specified by us so
let's take an example of our Facebook
page
say we fail a particular test case on
the Facebook application and then let's
see how we take a screenshot at that
particular moment when the test case
fails so let's go to the Facebook page
first and let's understand the use case
so in this Facebook page say if I am
signing up on this page I need to enter
all this field now as a part of demo
what I will do is I'll just enter the
first name and the surname and I will
click on the sign up button with this
test case it should basically not sign
me up rather it should give me some
error saying that you need to enter all
the fields and at that minute we are
going to take a screenshot okay so
that's our use case so let's see how do
we achieve that
so if I go to my Eclipse and let's say
we go to my screenshot test or Java I
have a method written here so and these
are the operations which I just
described which I am doing it here so
I'm going to just send keys my first
name to the first name field second name
into the third name field and then I'm
just going to click on the sign up
button now there are few things required
for us to do before we use the take
screenshot interface along with its
method which is the get screenshot us so
I said that this method stores the
screenshot taken in a file so that means
I need to provide it a file name and
also a location where it needs to be
placed so in our demo here in this test
class what I have done is I have created
a folder called screenshot in the same
project directory and then I am giving
it a file name called FB login dot PNG
so that means after the screenshot is
taken it is saved in the file called HB
login dot PNG and then it is stored in
the location screenshot folder and these
are the simple file operations of Java
which I use to achieve this so let's
execute this and see how this happens so
right now I have the screenshot folder
and it's an empty folder so after the
execution I am expecting that this
particular file would get created so
let's see that in action so I'll go
ahead and execute this Java program ok
so we have launched the facebook.com/
and then I entered the my first name
second name and it has also clicked on
signup after which it has given all this
red marks here and now this is what I'm
expecting in the screenshot so let's go
back to our Eclipse I will refresh this
folder so I'll say right-click and
refresh
okay I have this file created so let's
open this file and see hey so do you see
this this whole image has been captured
so now as a tester if at all this desk
is fails for me I can always open this
PNG file and see what actually happened
and I can debug my test case so this is
how you use screenshot functionality and
selenium level questions question 21 can
you type in a text box without using
send keys so this is a very favorite
question of any interviewer so you
should know that sometimes on an IE
browser whenever you use the send Keys
command it is pretty slow so some of the
performance of your some of your test
cases gets impacted so you need an
alternative way to use instead of using
the send Keys function and one such
alternative is using javascript executor
so selenium provides an interface called
JavaScript executor and this helps in
executing any JavaScript through your
selenium webdriver so you can do any
kind of function using this Java scripts
and one of the functions which we can do
is the send keys kind of a function now
how to replicate a send Keys function
using Java scripts so let's see an
example here now since this javascript
executor is an interface you cannot
create an object of this interface so
what you do you typecast it to your
driver object the way it is done here in
this example and then you use document
dot get element ID to get the actual
element on which you want to perform the
operations of sending the keys now what
is this document so it is an object
right so this document it's an object
that represents your HTML document which
is displayed in that window and this
document object has various properties
that refer to other object which allows
you the axis to modify any of your
document content so the argument which
you're passing to the Java execute
script is nothing but your JavaScript
now this JavaScript uses the document
object to identify your element and then
send the value which you need to send to
that element so let's see this in action
as how it works
so let me show you a small program here
all right so I have a method here
wherein I am trying to identify the
email field of your Facebook page so if
this is your
book application this is my email field
and instead of using sent keys here I'm
going to pass or email value to this and
how am I doing that using a JavaScript
executor right so if I execute this
particular Java program it is exactly
going to do the same function what I
would do otherwise using the same keys
so let's execute this and see if I can
see my users ID email in the Facebook
application so the Facebook application
is launched and there we go so we this
is the value which I have sent using my
JavaScript okay so this is how you can
use a JavaScript executor to replicate a
send keys method question 22 how to
select a value from your drop-down list
in the selenium webdriver so select
class is a selenium webdriver it is used
for selecting and deselecting options in
your drop-down list the objects of
select type can be initialized by
passing the drop-down web element as a
parameter to its constructor like in
this example I am saying select dropdown
equal to new select of test drop so test
drop is nothing but the web element
which I have identified using any
locating techniques after you create the
Select object then you have three
different methods available for actually
selecting your methods and what are
these methods one is select by index now
the index starts with zero in the list
so you can select any element from your
list using the index ID and then the
second one is select by values so this
is used to select an option based on its
brand new attribute select by visible
text so this is an option wherein you
can select a particular list item or an
option based on the text displayed in
the option so that means whatever text
you can see on your drop-down list is
what you will use it to identify that
particular element so let's see the demo
for this so I have again a same Facebook
application which are considered here
for demo so if you go to our Facebook
application first you know that there is
a drop-down menu here now this drop-down
is for selecting your birth date this
has a day values which you can select
the month values right and the year
now what I have done in my chorus first
thing is I have identified all this drop
down boxes using one of amusing mostly
the ID locating technique here so you
can use any of your choice so once I
identify the element I created the
Select object class for each of this and
I passed that web element to the
constructor of the Select class so now
my select element or the object is ready
to use so my next step what I need to do
is I need to go and select the actual
dates now in this use case what I want
is I want to select a date which is 10th
June 2005 that means on my select
drop-down of the day I should be able to
select the date ten now this I'm
achieving by using select by value and
then I am selecting the bun month based
on the index which is the index in this
case is 6 which will select the June
form and then the third one I am trying
to select it by visible text wherein I
am selecting the Year 2005
so when I execute this program let's see
how the date selection happens ok there
we go so it selected the ten the date
and the June month and the 2005 so this
is how you use select objects in
selenium question 23 what does the
switch to command - so switch to command
is used to switch between Windows frames
or even though alert pop-ups within your
application right so there are multiple
things which you can do with switch -
now sometimes in your web applications
say when you click on a button it opens
up a completely new browser window or
you will also see it opens up another
tab in your browser say for example
let's look at one of this application
which I have let me go to my browser and
say I launched HDFC Bank com alright so
this is my application say which you
want to test and when you launch this
first thing is I see this advertisement
pop-up which comes up which is right now
and unwanted pop-up so right now I'll
just close this and now if I want to
enter this HDFC Bank application first I
need to do a login so if I click on this
login button see there is a new window
which opens up and I need to go and
operate into this window so for any
further operations I want to do it on
this webpage I need to switch to this
window and then say I want to click on
internet banking and then continue with
my use case so now in this application
there are two windows open one is your
base window from where we actually
logged in and after I clicked on the
login there is a new window opened up
right so this is where your switch to
command will help us to switching to
this particular window to do any of the
operations on this web elements present
on this window okay now let's see how do
we actually do this so in order to do
this first you need to get the handle of
the window by using a command called
driver dot git window handle all right
so now when you use driver gate window
handle what you get is a unique
alphanumeric value which is an
identifier for that window and once you
get this you use a command called driver
dot switch to dot window and you pass
that handle which you have fetched
previously and this command will
actually switch to the current window
which is in your focus now you'll also
come across a case where there are
multiple windows open right now the
example what we saw we just had a single
window but say if you whenever you
launch an application say there are
multiple windows which are open so in
such case you can use something called
as get Windows handles right now get
windows handles what it does it it picks
up all the active windows at that point
of attack and using a for loop you can
read into every handle and then you do
your operation specific to your window
handles also there is another way
wherein you can switch back to your
parent window so if ever you want to
switch back to your parent window you
have to use the same command driver dot
switch to and the handle what you need
to provide here is your parent handle
all right so this is about Windows then
I also said switch to can be used for
your frames so what are frames frames
are usually used to divide your web
application or your web page or the on
the same domain into various different
windows or sections right so for us to
operate on elements which are in
different frames we need to first switch
to a particular frame and then use the
web elements on that so the same command
we'll be using now instead of window
here I would say driver dot switch to
dot free similarly even the alert
pop-ups can be handled using the same
command so in the case of alert what you
need to do is you have to say driver not
switch to dot L question 20 how to
upload
of file and selenium-webdriver a very
important concept in selenium-webdriver
we know that selenium-webdriver is
designed for automating web application
right and file upload is a very common
scenario which we get with every web
application which we are working with
now there are two ways to do a file
window or file upload operation one is
using the send keys which is the
simplest method and the other way is
using robot truss now there are certain
prereqs required for you to work with
the send keys option now if you are
using the send keys option what you
basically need to do is you need to type
in the complete path of the file along
with the file name right in the file
select input field now this element
where you are going to enter your file
name should have certain attributes one
of the attribute is it should have the
Tagus input right and also it should
have an attribute called type which
should have a value of file only then it
is possible for you to enter a file name
and upload the file okay that is by
using the send keys method then the
other way is using robot now when when
is that we need to use robot where
whenever you have an application and in
your application usually for your file
upload you have a button which says
upload a file and when you click on that
it opens a new window and this window is
your windows explorer window or a Finder
window depending on what operating
system you are working and these are the
native windows and we know that
selenium-webdriver directly cannot
handle the native applications so in
such case the robot class helps us in
managing these native windows so what
happens in the robot classes it helps
you manage your file upload dialog box
by simulating all the actions required
force selecting a particular file from
your dialog box and then you go ahead
upload them all right so this is the
example of using the send keys question
25 how to set rouser window size in
webdriver so you can either maximize the
window or set it to a certain value now
to do this you use a simple functions
provided by driver dot manage one of the
functions using driver dot manage is
driver dot manage dot window dot
maximize now this car
maximizes the current window and say you
want to set a particular window size
rather than maximizing it and then for
that you have a command called driver
dot manage dot window dot set size now
this set size takes an argument of the
type dimension class so this is
basically when you create a dimension
class you are passing the size of the
window which you want to create here
right so we use the dimension class
define the new dimensions of the window
and then pass the object of this
dimensions to the set size method this
is one way of doing it we also saw that
using javascript executors we can do any
kind of functionality so if you want to
minimize or maximize or set a different
size to your browser windows this can
also be done using a JavaScript okay
let's see a quick demo on how do we use
this driver dot manage dot set size on
to maximize command so let's go to my
Eclipse here so I have this method
return here so have two methods one
method where I'm saying I am going to
maximize the window this particular
command is where I'm saying driver dot
manage dot window dot maximize and I'm
launching our Facebook application so
first let's run this particular method
and see how our browser window behaves
so I just say execute this so now you
will see the whole window your browser
window is in maximized mode so now from
here I'm going to execute the other set
of lines here using which I'm going to
set a certain size now I will just
comment out these two lines and then
these are the two commands which I'm
going to use right so here what I have
done is I've defined an object of the
class dimension and I've used 600 600
which is the size of the window which I
want it to be and then using the set
size and passing this dimension object
to the set size method now let's see how
do we look at this browser window now
did you see that so it was at a certain
size and it just shrunk it shrunk
because I have used a smaller size
window question 26 when do we use find
element and find elements now find
element you can use this command to
access any single element on your page
and what does it return it returns an
object of the first matching element of
the specified locator and this is the
most common command what we use for
working with every web element on the
webpage
what does find elements find elements is
used to return a list of web elements so
each element which it identifies is
indexed with the number starting from
zero it's just like an array I'll show
you an example of that so that you can
understand it better so let's go to my
Eclipse here right so if you look at
this locators dot Java I have different
elements which I have identified using
different locating techniques right so
for that I use a simple command called
find element now say I have a use case
right wherein i want to fetch all the
web elements who have a class name
starting with the text input let's see
what that is so if I go to my Facebook
application if I try to inspect this say
first name right so I will say inspect
element now here if you see this
particular web element has a class name
starting with text called as input text
likewise there are many elements here
like even the surname if you look at it
it has a class name starting with input
text ok so if I have a use case like
that where I want all the web elements
on the Facebook page who have the class
name starting with the text input if I
have to do that that is when I say I am
going to use the driver dot find
elements so I say driver dot find
elements I give an XPath which is going
to pick up all those elements which has
the class name starting with input this
is my expert expression once I get all
the elements what am i doing I am going
to store it in a list at once I have all
this elements created it's in an array
I'm just going to traverse through the
array using an enhanced for-loop so in
this program in this test case I'm just
picking each and every element and
printing the attribute ID of each
element so if I execute this now we
should see all the elements on the
Facebook page which has the class name
starting with input and we should see
all the IDS of that so this is what we
are getting so you are around getting
nine to ten elements it has picked up
and all of them
the class name starting with input and
these are their different IDs question
27 what is pause on exception in
selenium ID so pause on exception is a
new feature of selenium ID it is one of
the brilliant debugger function which
this new selenium ID provides us what it
does is it enables us or when this
particular option is enabled the
execution of your test pauses if at all
there is any exception which occurs in
your test scripts and because of this
what you can do is you can go and handle
that error by say changing your command
in the script and then continue your
test execution so this helps in
debugging your code pretty well so
whenever there is an exception say for
example and web element which you are
trying to identify has all wrong right
in defer or it changes on your web page
then you can correct that command which
caused the exception and then resume the
test execution from that point onwards
so let's look at a simple use case and
see how exactly this works so for
example let's go to my browser here okay
so have a simple use case here where I
want to login into Facebook using my
email ID and password and what I have
done is I have created a script or
recorded a script using my selenium ID
so these are all the steps which it has
wherein it logs in to the Facebook
account then it clicks on the email
field enters the email this is my value
which I'm passing clicks on the password
field enters the password and it clicks
on the login button now this is a clean
test script and all my web elements are
correct here so whenever I am running
this test with this descript is going to
pass now say as an example say this
particular element which is my password
element say this ID changes so now
deliberately what I'm going to do I'm
just going to give it wrong idea
so if I give a wrong ID and if I execute
as test script now it is going to throw
an exception at this point so let's do
that so it's going to throw an exception
but now since I want to use the pause
and exception feature what I do is it's
available here it says pause and
exception by default it is switched off
so when you select this that means this
is been switched on and now if I execute
the script this is going to come into a
debug mode at this point where my
exception is going to be through so
see that so now I have this I've changed
this ID to wrong ID so I'll just say go
and run this current test so let's see
how it operates so let me just bring
this side-by-side so you can see here it
has entered the email and if you look
here in the console it is saying trying
to find the ID for which I've given PA
and for s which is a wrong writing so it
will look for some time whether it can
find an element with this particular ID
so let's wait for it to throw the
exception there we go so now it tried
enough and actually that step has failed
and there is an exception saying that
that particular web element is not fault
however my test case or the test script
did not exit it has come and paused and
it has entered into a debug hole here
paused in debug now as a tester or an
automation script writer what I can do
here is I can simply go and correct this
now I know this is my correct ID once I
correct this I can execute the rest of
the scripts right from this point so now
I have this option here if you go here
it says a resume test execution so I'm
just going to click on that so it is
going to go ahead and enter everything
is if you see here I entered email
password and in this des crypt what I am
doing is I'm entering my first name and
my surname instead of clicking on the
login button
so it went ahead and if you look here it
says if be test conflicted successfully
this is how the pause and exception
feature helps us question 28 how to
login into any website if it is showing
an authentication pop-up for username
and password which will be something
like this so this is a typical
authentication pop-up which you normally
see when you are dealing with some web
application right and to handle them we
use something called as an alert class
and alert class comes with a method
called authenticate using basically by
using this method what we are trying to
do is it helps us skip the basic HTTP
authentication box so how do we handle
it it is handled exactly the way we
handle any kind of alert box and
selenium now in this example first what
we need to do is we need to create a
weight object using an explicit weight
now this weight is for what it is for
the alert to pop up so we basically wait
until that authentication alert pops and
set the conditions in this explicit wait
for
or as Alert is present so that means
you're going to wait until your
authentication pop-up is seen on your
screen and then once you have that
authentication pop-up which is on your
screen that is when you need to go and
handle it now to handle it for your
alert class you're going to call a
method as I said using authenticate
using and to this you pass a parameter
now this parameter has to be your
username and password however the way
the parameters are passed here is using
a class object called user and password
now this user and password class it is a
part of selenium security package all
right and this is implemented from an
interface called credentials so you
create this object of class user and
password using the authentication
information which you have and then pass
this as parameter to your method called
authenticate using and this way you can
handle your authentication pop-up
question 29 what is the difference
between single and double slash in XPath
a very important question
and it's a very important thing for each
of you to understand single slash is
used to create an XPath with absolute
path that is the X part would be created
right from the starting node and the
starting node is slash HTML and the
double slash is created or it's a XPath
with relative path now relative path
this X part would be created or using
any starting location or anywhere within
the document for example I could start
with a div tag wherein if I mention
double slash and ER so this is going to
be treated as a relative path and
whatever conditions I am going to give
it is going to try and match those
attributes with the stack this is called
as a relative pub so why don't we just
go and take a look at how do we identify
an element using a relative as well as
an absolute path so if I go back to the
same application of the Facebook this is
my Facebook application now I have this
cro path installed which helps me in
identifying x parts of an element now
say i want to try and see what is the x
path of my element first name so in the
inspector tool i can see that it has a
tag input and it has a long class name
and it has multiple attributes which i
can use to identify the
element so if I go to micro park and
again try to match this element so if I
just over my mouse here now here you can
see this crow pod gives me both the part
one is the relative XPath and one is the
absolute XPath now look at the big
difference between these two relative
paths was as simple as using a slash
slash input which is the time and an
attribute called ID we are able to
identify this particular element same
thing if you want to use an absolute
path and you if you see here it will
start right from the slash HTML which is
your starting node of your HTML page and
then it travels down looking into each
of the parent and child under this until
it found this element input right so
this is absolute path so you can use
either of these paths to identify your
elements question xxx
how do you find broken links in selenium
webdriver now HTTP is designed for what
to enable communications between your
clients and servers and if you know
there are a few commands like get put
post now get is used to request data
from a specified resource put command is
used to send data over your server and
post is used to send data to the server
right now by using these links and
trying to figure out if the link is
valid or not what you can do is you can
use something called as head requests
now what our head requests head requests
are nothing but there's something like a
get request but they do not have a
response body and usually this is used
for checking that what a get request can
return before actually making a get
request like say before downloading a
large file you would send a head request
before sending the complete gate just to
know whether the link which is provided
for downloading or large file is a
genuine link or not and then looking at
the response code is what you decide
that so how do we do this
programmatically now selenium provides
something called as HTTP URL connection
class which has some methods to send
HTTP requests and to capture the HTTP
response codes like the ones which you
see it on the screen so if we have to
see how do we do that now first thing
the logic behind how do we get this
broken links is you get all the URLs on
your website first after getting all the
URLs now how do you get the you are
by using the tag a like it is done here
so once you get the complete list of all
URLs you also check for a non well or
non null or a blank ones that is one
kind of a check which you can put after
that you create an HTTP connection
object with each of the URL and you open
the connection of the URL and you send
the request now this request whatever
you are going to send you are going to
send the header request to just to get
the head and not the complete get
request now only thing what you are
interested in getting a response code so
once you get the response code what you
have to do is you have to check the
response code against all your response
code now typically when you're checking
for your response code any response code
above 400 is treated as a client edge
rest all the links below 400 are all the
valid next so here if you see 4 0 4 you
have a response for let's link not 4 400
is a bad request for 0 1 is unauthorized
so you can do a simple check that where
it says if your response code is above
500 then that particular link has an
error and that is probably going to be
or invalidly so let's see that in action
as how exactly the code is going to look
and how do we achieve that now I have
our test case written here called broken
links to Java now here what I'm doing is
I'm logging into Facebook comm and then
I'm fetching all the elements with the
tag a now when I say I'm fetching all
the elements with the tag that means I'm
going to get all the xref element from
the page and once I get that using a for
loop I'm going to inspect each and every
URL what I'm going to fetch as I said my
first check would be to see if it is a
null or is it an empty if I find an
empty or null value in the URL I'm just
going to ignore that and continue the
loop and this is where I actually do the
connection with my URL so I create an
HTTP URL connection with the URL which I
have picked it up from my website then I
do this I send a request here the head
request to get a response code so once I
get this response code is what I put a
if-else statement and check if my
response code is greater than or equal
to 400 so if I find that if my response
code is more than 400 that means this
particular URL link is
and that is how identify so once you
identify a particular URL which is
broken you can make use of that
information or share it with your
developers and get it fixed so let's go
ahead and execute this so in this test
case basically what I'm going to do is
I'm just printing out all the URLs and
I'm printing the ones which are valid
and ones which are broken
since it's a facebook.com website I do
not have any broken URL but this is just
a logic of how do we find out broken
your it so if you look here a lot of
websites which is getting listed with
safe is a valid link so that means it is
getting a response code which is more
than 500 so this is what we saw in the
demo as how do I I trade after I select
all the links on the page and then how
do I determine whether it's a valid link
or it's a broken leg alright so that
brings us to the end of this interview
questions
I hope this should help you and help you
to get through any of the interviews
which you're going to attend and also
this acts as a pretty good information
set for you so thank you very much for
viewing this video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here